all right cars have a history and
personality much like jc
and mecum auto auctions is giving you
the opportunity
to buy the car of your dreams jc is live
at the convention center with the
details i'm sure he didn't choose this
assignment though
i'm sure of it
rocky and kendall i got to tell you i am
in heaven the makeup
auto auctions is here in las vegas 600
beautiful cars
and motorcycles up for auction this
weekend now normally this is a huge
event
thousands of people come down here to
the convention center because of the
pandemic everything is closed off but
the auction is still
taking place you guys can jump online
and bid on the car of your dreams
it's going to be on nbc sports this
weekend as well
and let's talk about some of the
vehicles first because this car behind
me
lands let's get a shot of this 1972
chevelle because this is very special
first off
this is a custom design by counts
customs here in las vegas
it was featured on counting cars and
here's the deal guess who owns that car
mark andre fleury that's mark andre
flurry's actual
chevelle that he's selling here at mecum
auctions and if you win
that car if you're the winning bidder
you'll also get an autographed
jersey from mark andre fleury isn't that
insane that is gorgeous uh lance coming
down this way really fast like 30
seconds
so many different cars to bid on you can
jump on meko's website if you want to
register and bid on one of these insane
vehicles
this car here is a 1933 mercedes
benz this is just gorgeous look at the
beautiful paint color
the white walls kendall i can see you
cruising the strip
in this uh mercedes-benz right here and
rocky
spin over here rocky i can see you
cruising the strip
and this gorgeous 1967
ferrari beautiful cars here mecum
auctions you can watch it online or in
nb sports
nbc sports this weekend i'm gonna send
it back to you guys in the studio
accurate jc accurate all right we'll
check in with you at the 4pm newscast